das einzige was ich weiß wenn ich alt
bin dass ich keine rente mehr habe inter
gut alles gut aber ich persönlich muss
gestehen dass ich an die staatliche
rente nicht mehr wirklich glaube an die
gesetzliche rente glauben das ist so
eine sache ich habe letztens auf
instagram gefragt woran ihr beim
stichwort rente denkt darauf habe ich
super viele nachrichten bekommen viele
von euch meinten sie hätten angst dass
die rente im alter nicht reicht andere
fühlten sich schlecht informiert und
wissen gar nicht so richtig was sie
weiter erwartet die instabil ist unser
rentensystem wirklich was müsste man
eigentlich tun um das rentensystem zu
retten und welche lösungen haben andere
länder wie zum beispiel schweden
[Musik]
hey ich bin aminata berlin willkommen
bei context in der heutigen zeit kommen
und den themen so irrsinnig schnell dass
man kaum noch hinterher kommt umso
wichtiger ist es dass wir das große
ganze nicht aus den augen verlieren
dafür ist contexta um aktuelle themen in
den größeren zusammenhang zu setzen
heute geht es um das deutsche
rentensystem und das ist nicht erst seit
kurzem ein problem und wenn man bedenkt
dass mein jahre lang einen recht
erheblich hohen betrag einzahlen muss
und sieht was man dann am ende raus
bekommen nach den augen wirklichen
berechnungen und sieht es eigentlich
nicht sehr günstig auf meine generation
ist tief besorgt über die frage ob
dieses rentenversicherungssystem zukunft
hat du wirst das einzige was ich weiß
ist wenn ich alt bin das ist keine rente
habe man denkt ja immer das erste
generation 1000 praktika später
berufseinstieg und tendenziell
unterbezahlt so viel angst vor der rente
hat aber auch schon die jungen leute von
vor über 50 jahren hat das thema
umgetrieben übrigens wenn du mehr davon
sehen willst wie früher über das thema
gesprochen wurde dann schau mal in der
mediathek vorbei aber so alt die als
junger menschen um ihre rente ist so alt
auch die antwort von politikerinnen und
politiker auf diese angst wir machen
keine revolution wir machen rentenreform
und es gilt auch der schatz zum
mitschreiben die rente ist sicher
allerdings jedes mal mit einer neuen
zahl verwirren kann wir stellen sicher
dass es nicht abwärts geht und das haben
die älteren mit bürger unseres landes
verdient und im alter eine verlässliche
rente aber was heißt das eigentlich eine
stabile verlässliche rente sprach ich
nicht einfach für mich selbst eine
gewisse summe an die ich dann im alter
vom kopf hauen kann wie das rentensystem
genau funktioniert und wen der mann geld
fließt und was ich am schluss von der
ganzen sache habe das habe ich lange
zeit selbst nicht hinterfragt lasst uns
deswegen noch mal kurz einen schritt
zurückgehen und einen kleinen renten
crashkurs einlegen
das system das heutzutage in deutschland
besteht hat schon konrad adenauer
eingeführt 1957 reformiert adenauer die
rente gründlich die jungen zahlen nun
mit beiträgen die renten der alten im
umlageverfahren eine generation steht so
für die andere ein
1957 das sogenannte umlageverfahren ist
geboren das bedeutet die beiträge die
beschäftigte während ihrer berufszeit in
die rentenkasse zahlen fließen direkt in
die rente der aktuellen senioren die
rentenversicherung funktioniert also
nicht wie eine spardose die unser staat
ist bis zum alter aufbewahrt aktuell
zahlt monatlich 18 6 prozent unseres
sohnes in die rentenversicherung die
eine hälfte übernimmt die arbeitgeberin
die andere hälfte der arbeitnehmer der
45 jahre lang durchschnittlich verdient
und beiträge in die rentenkasse gezahlt
hat kriegt aktuell fast 50 prozent des
deutschen durchschnittseinkommens
doch das ganze system hat einen großen
haken die geburtenrate sinkt seit den
60er jahren hinzu kommt die eigentlich
schöne tatsache dass die deutschen immer
länger leben doch jedes jahr mehr kostet
auch ein weiteres jahr rente mehr
weniger einnahmen steigende ausgaben
ohne gegensteuern das weiß jeder
kaufmann hieße dass irgendwann pleite
als das umlagesystem in den 50er jahren
eingeführt wurde kam sechs
erwerbspersonen für eine rentnerin oder
einen renten auf heute müssen schon nur
noch drei erwerbspersonen ein rentner
oder eine finanzieren und bis 2050
könnte sich das verhältnis auf 221
verschärfen da müssen zwei
arbeitnehmende genug in die rentenkasse
einzahlen um einen einzigen rentner oder
eine rentnerin zu versorgen das ding ist
nur weder die jungen wollen mehr
beiträge zahlen noch wollen die älteren
auf ihre rente verzichten wir sind junge
leute ist eines tages bezahlen müssen
und ehrlicherweise aber ich persönlich
daraufhin davon kann ich da besteht
jetzt mal wirklich unsere rente bekommen
diese und zu stehen bleibt also nur
einer übrig der in die bresche springen
kann der staat im jahr 2020 hat er
ungefähr 100 milliarden euro zur
rentenkasse zugeschossen das war mehr
als ein viertel des gesamten
bundeshaushalts
wenn die politiker in weiter so
rentenpolitik betreiben wie bisher dann
werden im jahr 2045 schon mehr als die
hälfte des bundeshaushalts in die rente
fließen waren experten und das hat
auswirkungen auf ganz andere bereiche
das heißt wir werden dann gezwungen bei
der bildung zu sparen tun wir ja jetzt
eigentlich schon zu viel wir können uns
kaum leisten auf andere dinge einzugehen
die infrastruktur zu erneuern oder
vernünftig aber dem klimawandel
umzugehen alles kostet geld und
wir können uns nicht leisten mehr als
die hälfte des bundeshaushaltes in die
rente zu stecken jetzt könnte man sagen
rente ist eben sozialpolitik und die
darf ruhig vom staat unterstützt werden
viele menschen etwa solche die wenig
verdient haben oder nicht durchgehend in
die rentenkasse eingezahlt haben wie zum
beispiel auch selbstständige sind im
alter schlecht abgesichert also das ist
ein großes zeichen für deutschland dass
es überhaupt
für die eigenen leute die im land leben
die rentner nicht genügend geld haben um
das sie wurde unten kommen aber was dann
schon immer so dass der staat so viel
geld in die rentenkasse stecken musste
damit dieses system generationenvertrag
überhaupt funktionieren kann
ein blick auf die statistik zeigt
konzipiert war das system so dass es
sich grösstenteils selbst tragen kann
1957 als das umlageverfahren eingeführt
wurde ganze stadt nur 3,4 milliarden
d-mark dazu also nur ein bruchteil von
dem was der staat heute zuschießt
seitdem ist der betrag ziemlich stark
angewachsen klar geld hatte früher noch
einen ganz anderen wert der
staatshaushalt zwar viel kleiner als
heute aber auch prozentual also gemessen
am gesamt verfügbaren budget der
regierung sind die ausgaben für die
rente insgesamt gestiegen und dann sagen
politiker von heute so was und ich will
gerne sagen dass ich sehr aufgeregt und
empört bin wenn all die experten
experten die uns in den 90er jahren so
viele dinge gesagt haben sich jetzt
wieder melden sie haben uns damals
gesagt wir würden jetzt zu dieser zeit
viel höhere beiträge zahlen als wir
jetzt zahlen tatsächlich zahlen wir
geringere beiträge zur
rentenversicherung als zurzeit von
helmut kohl doch was bringt es uns wenn
die beitragssätze nicht steigen aber wie
er das immer größer werdende
finanzierungsloch trotzdem zahlen müssen
nur eben über steuern statt über
beitragssätze aber tatsächlich gab es
auch eine bemühung das deutsche
rentensystem so zu reformieren dass sich
jährlich hunderte milliarden notwendig
werden um es über wasser zu halten
stichwort riester rente kommt euch
vielleicht bekannt vor
werden meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren leistungen des staates kürzen
eigenverantwortung fördern und mehr
eigenleistung von jedem einzelnen
abfordern müssen getrieben von der
wirtschaftlich schwierigen lage und von
hohen arbeitslosenzahlen entschließt
sich die rot grüne regierung unter der
hat schröder dazu ein
wirtschaftsfreundliches reformpaket
durchzusetzen die so genannte agenda
2010 mit dabei ziemlich krasse
rentenreform unter anderem führt die
regierung den sogenannten
nachhaltigkeitsfaktor ein der dafür
sorgen soll dass ihr denn nicht mehr in
genau den selben tempo steigen wie die
löhne doch schon bereits vor dem jahr
2003 also vor offiziellem beginn der
agenda 2010 ergänzt walter riester in
der damalige arbeits und sozialminister
das system der altersvorsorge um ein
neues standbein
sozialversicherungsrente eine
kapitalgedeckte vorsorge wir ergänzen
das eine system mit dem anderen system
wir stärken die stärken und bauen die
schwächen ab statt wie bislang
größtenteils auf die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung zu setzen wäre es da
dass die bürgerinnen und bürger auch
noch privat fürs alter vorsorgen also
das was zum beispiel selbstständige in
vielen fällen jetzt und machen das
konzept der riester rente wenn
bürgerinnen und bürger über die
gesetzliche versicherung hinaus noch
produkte zur altersvorsorge kaufen
unterstützt der stadt das mit zuschüssen
und steuererleichterung diese staatliche
unterstützung wurde damals für eine
ganze menge von finanzprodukten
freigegeben tausende unterschiedliche
verträge stehen zur auswahl angebote
gibt es also reichlich vom banksparplan
über die vorsorge bei aktienfonds bis
hin zu versicherungspolicen reicht die
palette das große reformprojekt riester
rente ist allerdings hinter den
erwartungen zurückgeblieben zu hoch die
gebühren zu intransparent die verträge
zu gering unter umständen die rendite
sagen kritiker in das schreckt
potenzielle kundinnen und kunden ab eine
riester rente nein habe ich nicht nein
nein nein habe ich nicht mehr genießt
rente bis letztlich etwas was dem
kleinen mann der kleinen frau nicht
wirklich hilft ganz im gegenteil mag die
private vorsorge von arbeitsminister
riester auch nicht so funktioniert haben
wie man sich erhofft hatte die
rentenreform aus den frühen 2000er
jahren gegen für viele expertinnen in
die richtige richtung wir sollten die
rente in ruhe lassen sie ist im grunde
genommen saniert aber derjenige der sie
saniert hat das war der schröder mit
seiner agenda 2010 die hat uns die
rentenreformen beschert die verbrauchten
herr müntefering unter der ersten
kanzlerschaft merkel hat dann das
rentenzugangsalter auf 67 erhöht und das
alles waren völlig richtige entscheidung
wir dürfen daran nicht drehen doch genau
das ist in den letzten jahren passiert
die grundrente wird grundsicherung im
alter die mittelrhein wird das gesamte
niveau stabilisieren an der haltelinie
haben was die beiträge betrifft der
versuch von riester das deutsche
rentensystem zu verschlanken wurde in
den jahren danach wieder stück für stück
rückgängig gemacht da wäre
beispielsweise die rente mit 63 ein
prestige projekt von andrea nahles wir
sind langjährig versicherte betroffen
die 45 jahre auf dem buckel haben und
die einfach früher raus können ohne
abschläge hinzunehmen die haben sich das
verdient
auch die mütter rente ein wunschprojekt
der csu die priorität der csu heißt eine
hütte und die 2021 eingeführte
grundrente sind sozialpolitische
maßnahmen die enorme kosten verursachen
die grundrente ist ein zuschlag von um
die 75 euro auf die bestehenden rente
für all jene die 35 jahre grundrechten
zeiten vorzeigen können das kann arbeit
beinhalten aber auch kindererziehung und
pflege von angehörigen
das meine damen und herren ist ein
wesentlicher sozialpolitischer
meilenstein weil es das vertrauen von
menschen in die rentenversicherung
stärke weil klar ist dass diejenigen die
lebt gearbeitet haben die kinder erzogen
haben die angehörigen pflicht haben mehr
verdient haben als das was sie bisher
bekommen haben schließlich hat sich die
große koalition
2018 auf eine regelung geeinigt die sich
die doppelte haltelinie nennt sie besagt
dass das rentenniveau also das
verhältnis von durchschnittliche rente
zu durchschnittlichen lohn in
deutschland nicht unter 48 prozent
fallen darf und dass die beitragssätze
in die rentenversicherung auf höchstens
20 prozent begrenzt werden ja das ist
leider die erwartbare einigung zu lasten
dritter nämlich zulasten der
beitragszahler steuerzahler und
insbesondere jungen generation wir
bräuchten eine politik die die rente
dauerhaft zukunftssicher macht von all
diese maßnahmen von der grundrente die
rente mit 63 und von der mutter rente
profitieren jetzt erstmal zwei gruppen
die die bereits in rente sind und die
das bald sein werden und zwar die baby
boomer damit sind die geburts starken
jahrgänge der 50er und 60er jahre
gemeint
politiker eine politikerin muss sich um
diese gruppe kümmern das ist die riesige
wählergruppe und die jungen leute
kriegen entsprechend weniger
aufmerksamkeit und anteil zumal sie ja
erst ab 18 jahren wählen dürfen um das
klarzustellen ich könnte natürlich jeder
mutter und jedem vater jeder
frührentnerin und jedem geringverdiener
die rente nur es muss auch ein
funktionierendes system geben dass die
kosten dieser extra maßnahmen entdeckt
politiker in die rentenpolitik der
letzten jahre verantwortet haben rechnen
sich das alles so aus wenn mehr leute
arbeiten die dann wiederum steuern
zahlen lässt sich das loch in der
rentenkasse stopfen und es gelingt dann
viele menschen in arbeit mit
ordentlichem einkommen haben darauf muss
man sich konzentrieren
ändert nur eben nichts an der tatsache
dass trotzdem die steuerzahler innen zur
kasse gebeten werden dabei gebe es
vorschläge wie man das rentensystem
stabiler aufstellen könnte eine
naheliegende idee das
renteneintrittsalter erhöhen
berater des wirtschaftsministeriums
haben eine rente mit 68
vorgeschlagen andernfalls drohten ab
2025 schockartig steigende
finanzierungsprobleme in der
gesetzlichen rentenversicherung so die
experten zugegeben noch länger als
bislang vorgesehen 67 arbeiten das
klingt nicht gerade verlockend eine
zweite idee wäre das auch beamte und
selbstständige in die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung einzahlen denn selbst
der nähe können teils noch selbst
entscheiden ob sie in die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung wollen und bestimmte
berufsgruppen wie etwa selbstständig die
rechtsanwälte können in eigene
rentenkassen einzahlen auch beamte
kriegen ihre rente aus einer separaten
pensionskasse würden für zwanzig dreißig
jahre wahrscheinlich zusätzliche
beitragszahler gewinnen für das
gesetzliche rentensystem und erst dann
zusätzliche renten zahlen müssen und
dieser übergang der wäre natürlich gut
das rentenniveau müsste gar nicht so
stark sinken weil auch die beitragssätze
nicht so stark steigen nur danach kehrt
sich das alles wieder rum und wir stehen
letzten endes vor denselben ungelösten
demografischen problemen wie bisher
sowohl die erhöhung des
renteneintrittsalters als auch die
verpflichtende einzahlung von beamten
und selbstständigen in die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung würde das bestehende
system lediglich ergänzen doch es gibt
auch reformvorschläge die den
generationenvertrag an sich verändern
würden zumindest teilweise und deswegen
brauchen wir bei unserer demografischen
entwicklung dringend einen
kapitalbildenden faktor wir haben
vorgeschlagen das schwedische modell zu
übernehmen eine aktien renten in die
gesetzliche rente zu integrieren das was
die fdp vorschlägt haben auch in
unterschiedlicher ausführung und unter
anderem namen die spd cdu csu und die
grünen vor ein teil der altersvorsorge
über den kapitalmarkt abzuwickeln die
hoffnung ist dass man künftige
rentnerinnen und rentner an den gewinn
des kapitalmarkts beteiligt und so
erträge für die rente rausholt im
unterschied zur momentan besteht und
gesetzlichen rentensystem würden die
beiträge die wir heute 1 nicht direkt
für die rente der älteren benutzt
sondern angelegt als vor bedient wie in
so vielen fällen skandinavien genauer
schweden und sie entschloss sich die
regierung vor 21 jahren zu einer
zusätzlichen finanzierung der rente über
aktien und anleihefonds 2,5 prozent des
bruttoeinkommens müssen dafür
zurückgelegt werden etwa in den
staatlichen fonds ab der schwedische
staatsfonds at 7 ist sowas wie das
vorzeige kind einer kapitalgedeckten
altersvorsorge denn er investiert das
geld zu sehr niedrigen kosten und wirft
durchschnittlich eine ordentliche
rendite ab ob es in deutschland gelingen
würde so einen erfolgreichen staatsfonds
aufzusetzen bleibt abzuwarten dennoch
ist die idee einer akzente eine
überlegung wert aber natürlich gibt es
auch gute einwände gegen eine
kapitalgedeckte rente stelle mir immer
meine großeltern vor die das jetzt
erkläre dass ein teil ihrer
altersvorsorge künftig über irgendwas
was womit sie sich noch nie beschäftigt
haben an der börse passieren soll da
würden viele gerade in deutschland
erstmal sagen lass mal wir machen das
bitte so weiter wie bisher also ich
finde eine akzente sehr spannend kann
mir aber nicht vorstellen meine
altersvorsorge komplett vom kapitalmarkt
abhängig zu machen mich wollt ihr
interessieren was ihr dazu sagt schreibt
man das meinen die kommentare wenn ich
mir die riesige finanzierungslücke in
der deutschen rentenkasse ansehe macht
mit es echt sorge und ich bin verdammt
froh dass ich nicht in den schuhen
derjenigen stecke die dieses problem
lösen müssen wenn die frage bleibt ja
wer soll das alles bezahlen die jungen
die alten der kapitalmarkt ich
jedenfalls finde es sehr wichtig sich
schon früh mit der altersvorsorge zu
befassen und nicht erst damit anzufangen
wenn man schon kurz vor der rente steht
ich hoffe ich konnte euch dabei helfen
das thema rente in den kontext zu setzen
wenn ihr mehr zum thema wissen wollt
dann schaut hier beim ist allwissend
figur vorbei und hier gibt es eine
weitere folge kontext mit meinem
kollegen theo koll